السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف بوريل ان دول الاتحاد ستواصل الدفاع
من اجل تسويه سياسيه للصراع الجاري في
السودان رغم اجلاء الدبلوماسيين
والمواطنين الاوروبيين منه واشار بوريل
الى ان الاتحاد يجري اتصالات بالبرهان
في اطلاق النار مؤكدا ان المجتمع الدولي
قادر على الضغط لتحقيق ذلك
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما الذي تكشفه تصريحات
بوريل بشان مدى استعداد وقدره دول الغربيه
للتدخل بنحو فاعل لايقاف القتال في
السودان وحمل اطرافه على الحوار والتسويه
السلميه وما هي الاعتبارات التي تحكم
الموقف الاوروبي اي تفاعل محتمل لاطراف
القتال في السودان مع مثل هذا التوجه من
قبل الدول الغربيه وكيف نقرا دورهما في
الاسراع باجلاء الرعايه الغربيين ودلاله
ذلك الاجلاء بخصوص موقفي ودور الدول
المعنيه به
والى ماذا قد يذهب الموقف الغربي من
المشهد السوداني بالنظر الى الاحتمالات
المتباينه التي قد يذهب في اتجاهها وما هي
البدائل المطروحه في التعامل مع ارتفاع
حده القتال او تراجعها
[موسيقى]
رغم تتالي الاصوات الداعيه في الداخل
والخارج طرفي الصراع في السودان الى وقف
اطلاق النار وتغليب الحكمه وتحكيم الحوار
فان الاقتتال يستمر بين طرفين وسط تحذيرات
من تاثيراته القريبه والبعيده وعلى وقع
عمليات اجلاء موظفي ورعايه دول الاجنبيه
قال ممثل السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل انه تحدث الى كل من
البرهان وحماتي وشدد على ضروره حمايه
المدنيين وكان الاتحاد الاوروبي قد دعا
لوقف فوريا للقتال وقال بوريل لان المجتمع
الدولي بوسعه الضغط على طرفي القتال من
اجل وقف الاحتراب بينهما دعوه لم تبدو
بعيده في شيء عما ادلى به وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انطون بلانك في تصريحات جديده
قال فيها ان واشنطن في تواصل مستمر مع
شركائها الاقليبيين والدوليين وما طرفي
النزاع لانهاء القتال بينهما وبينما لم
توضع بعد اليات التنسيق والتحرك لتحقيق
هذا الهدف قال وزير الخارجيه الكيني
ان الرئيس الكيني اقترح مبادره للتواصل
الى حل سلمي للازمه السودانيه متوا شدد
على ان معالجه الازمه يجب ان تتم ضمن
الاتحاد الافريقي وعبر منظمه
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من بروكسيل
السفير جيمس موران مستشار وشؤون الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا السابق في دائره
العمل الخارجي للاتحاد الاوروبي وايضا
معنا من نيويورك دكتور عبد الحميد الصيام
الخبير في شؤون الامم المتحده ومن باريس
محمد تورشين الكاتب والباحث السياسي
السوداني مرحبا بكم جميعا ابدا معك ما هي
الاعتبارات والحسابات التي تحكم الموقف
الاوروبي وتحركاته ما بين المصالح
والهواجس والمحاذير
الى الاعتبارات الاوليه والاساسيه كما
تحدث السيد جوزيف بوريل اليوم
هي
ندخر وسعا من الجانب الاوروبي من اجل
حمايه سلامه وامني الاوروبيين في السودان
وفي اخر اربع او ثمانيه واربعين ساعه كان
هناك عمليات اجلاء في وضع خطير ولكن يبقى
الالاف بعض من الاوروبيين العالقين في
الخرطوم الان هذه هي الاولويه الاولى
ثانيا
ربما ليست بالاهميه نفسها طبعا ولكن يجب
ان تكون زياده الضغوطات على طرفي النزاع
من اجل ان يجلسا الى طاوله المباحثات
ويوقف هذا النزاع المدمر الجاري حاليا
وطبعا
المصلحه هي مصلحه الشعب السوداني ومصلحتنا
جميعا في اوروبا وفي غيرها لان ذلك من
شانه ان او اذا استمر النزاع سوف يضغط على
الموارد الانسانيه وايصال المساعدات
بالاضافه الى موجه الهجره والنازحين
الداخليين
وسودان كان من قبل احد مصادر الهجره غير
النظاميه
وطبعا هذا امر يؤرق بال القاده الاوروبيين
نحن لا نريد المزيد من هذا النوع من
الضغوطات
كلما انتهى النزاع
سريعا كان ذلك افضل بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك
الحاجه والضروره لاحترام العقوبات الامميه
على السودان بما فيه حظر الاسلحه الذي تم
تجديده منذ شهر تقريبا على جميع الدول ان
تحترم حظر الاسلحه هذا بشكل كامل ان توفير
الاسلحه الى السودان الان
يعزز من النزاع ويزيد من الوفيات اذن
تحدثت عن ضغوط على طرفي النزاع هل لهذه
الضغوط من قبل دول الاتحاد الاوروبي وحتى
من قبل الدول الغربيه المعنيه بمتابعه ما
يجري كالولايات المتحده ايضا هل لديها
محددات
لممارسه الضغوط غير
التصريحات الشفهيه
هي محدوده طبعا هذه المحددات قليله وان
نقول ان اوروبا الولايات المتحده لوحدهما
قادرتان على القيام بذلك هذا امر
ليس منطقيا او ليس واقعيا نحن بحاجه الى
ضغوطات من الدول الافريقيه دول العربيه في
المنطقه من اجل ايقاف هذا النزاع المدمر
الذي لن يقودنا الى اي مكان
نتحدث عن فصيلين عسكريين مدججين بالسلاح
سوف لن يصل الى اي مكان يجب الضغط لكي
يوقف ذلك ولكن ايضا يجب ان نحرص على عدم
توفير الاسلحه لهما من اي طرف كان والا
سبب ذلك المزيد من الدمار سيد محمد كيف
تنظر الى طبيعه المقاربه
الاوروبيه الامريكيه الغربيه بطبيعه الحال
لما يجري في السودان هل يرقى الخطاب
لمستوى ما يجري وهل كانت موفقه في الحديث
عن هذا المشهد ومتابعته متابعتها له
الكرام وكذلك المشاهدين الاكارم انا في
تقديري تداعيات هذه الحرب وكذلك رؤيه كل
طرف فتختلف من واقع لاخر لاعتبارات عديده
اولا الاتحاد الاوروبي الان هو الاكثر
حرصا بان تعود الاوضاعف الى السودان الى
ما كانت اليه من قبل او استقرار نسبي يوسف
ذلك في محاوله احكام السيطره على تدفقات
اللاجئين وكذلك كل شيء من ان هشاشه
الاوضاع الابنيه في السودان ايضا تكون
معبر للمجموعات الارهابيه ومعلومه من
السودان متاخم لعدد من الاحزمه التي تنشط
فيها الجماعات وان كان الساحل او حوض
بحيره كذلك القرن الافريقي اما الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الان الظاهر ان
المحدداتها التي تجعلها تتحرك في هذه
المساحات هي مرتبطه ايضا الى ارتباط وثيق
بدر في المنطقه
هنالك تصريح لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي تحدث
عنهم قلقون بوجودنا في المعادله انا في
تقدير النتيجه لعدم وضوح الرؤيه بشكل جدي
كذلك للتصريحات التي صدرت والتقارير من
واشنطن اعرفي تقديري بتجعل الكثير من
القوه الازمه من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهي صاحبه الكعبه العالم او
الراجح في هذه المعادله ان تتريس قليلا
حتى تصدر الموقفها النهائي بالرغم من ان
هنالك مناورات من شانها محاوله الضغط على
طرفين الصراع مبدئيا بايقاف هذا
الحرب او هدنه مستمره لفترات طويله والان
هنالك احاديث عن هذه الهدنه حتى يتسنى
للبعض التوصل الى تفاهمات ونلاحظ بان الان
هنالك تصريحاته احاديث حتى الان لم نتاكد
من دقتها بان هنالك مبادره مطروحه بان يتم
يلتقي محمد حمدان دقله وكذلك عبد الفتاح
البرهان في الرياض بمبادره مسنوده من
الاتحاد الاوروبي وكذلك الاتحاد الافريقي
فضلا عن الامارات العربيه المتحده ومصر
فكل هذه هي معطيات وتحركات في تقديري
حقيقه موقفه المجتمع الدولي بشان الازمه
في السودان هو مرتبط
بمخرجات او بتوصيات او بقرارات مجلس الامن
الدولي في الجلسه المزمنه يعني عقاده يوم
غدا اذا لم تحدث بعض المستجدات ونلاحظ بان
الارز متحمسه وغير راغبه في في ادراج
ملف السودان في اجنده مجلس الامن يوم غدا
فبالتالي كل هذه التقاطعات والتجاذبات
الدوليه في تقديري لا يمكن التعويل عليها
كثيرا في فرض واقع
سياسيا في السودان والحاله السودانيه لا
يغير بعيده او بمنع عن الحالات التي حدثت
في المنطقه سواء كان في دول افريقيا التي
حدثت فيها انقلابات عسكريه مؤخرا او ثورات
الربيع العربي ونلاحظ ان دور المجتمع
الدولي شبه معدوم ومحدود جدا هذا يحبني
للسؤال للسيد عبد الحميد صيام عن يعني هل
تتفق مع سيد محمد بان ما يخرج عن
الامم المتحده واجتماعات مجلس الامن سيكون
هو محدد رئيسي
في اتجاهات التحركات الدوليه تحركات
المجتمع الغربي تحديدا
لمقاربته للازمه السودانيه مع العلم بان
يعني مجلس الامن فيه عوامل ربما قد لا
تنتج ما تراه المجموعه الغربيه مناسبا لها
مثل الوجود الصيني الروسي الذي قد يناك في
الغرب في الملف السوداني
شكرا جزيلا تحيه لك
ولضيوف والمشاهدين الكرام
يعني نتوقع غدا ان يكون هناك جلسه مشاورات
مغلقه بعد الجلسه الرسميه المخصصه لقضيه
فلسطين تحت رئاسه وزير الخارجيه الروسي
السيد سيرجي لافروف
بعد انتهاء الجلسه عن فلسطين سيتم اجراء
مشاورات عن السودان لكن بصراحه
قدره المجتمع الدولي الان على التاثير على
الصراع تكاد تكون ضئيله يعني هناك
عده وجهات نظر وهناك دول لا تاثير لها حتى
لو
اصدرت هذه التصريحات هناك دول محدده لها
دور في المساله السودانيه وخاصه دول
الخليج
ولكن حتى هذه الدول والتي لها علاقات
مميزه مع هذا الطرف وذاك
امكانياتها الان للضغط على الطرفين
تكون معدومه لان هناك من قرر ان ينتصر
عسكريا على الاخر وعمليه الانتصار العسكري
حاليا غير متوفره لاي منهما لان النظام
ليس في ساحات مفتوحه المعارك ليست في
مناطق يستطيع الجيش ان يحسم المعركه بسرعه
هذه معارك تجري داخل المدن هناك تحصينات
هنا وهناك هناك اسلحه
تدفقت على الطرفين منذ وقت طويل من يعتقد
ان دجله ممكن هزيمته بسرعه فهو مخطئ لان
لديه اسلحه
ويعني مستودعات من الاسلحه تبين وجودها
ويبدو انه كان يستعد لهذا هذه المواجهه
منذ وقت وهناك دول تدعمه كذلك لذلك بصراحه
وضع مجلس الامن الان لا يتعدى عن كون
المناشده هو اطلاق بيانات كما اطلقوا في
اليوم الثاني للمواجهات كان هناك بيان صدر
عن مجلس الامن يناشد الاطراف بالتوقف عن
القتال فورا والامين العام ايضا اطلق عده
مبادرات
بطلب من الطرفين ان يلتزم بهدنه مدتها
ثلاثه ايام لم يلتزم بها احد السيد
مبعوث الامين العام الخاص والموجود في
الخرطوم والذي اكد ان حركته محدوده الان
ايضا ناشد الطرفين
هدنه مدتها ثلاث ساعات في بدايه القتال لم
يتم احترامها فكيف ممكن الان ان يصدر مجلس
الامن موقفا يتم احترامه نحن نتوقع ان
يكون هناك موقف موحد يناشد الطرفين
بالالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار والعوده الى
المفاوضات لكن امكانيات
تاثير على الطرفين قليله هناك فقط دوله او
دولتان في منطقه الخليج ممكن ان تؤثر على
الاحداث اذا فعلا وضعت جهدا اكبر من
الجهود الحاليه المنصبه على اخلاء
المدنيين كل الدول الان تعمل على اخراج
مدنييها من الخرطوم وهذا دليل شؤم ودليل
خطير لان المواجهات ستستمر وربما يتكرر
سيناريو جنوب السودان بين سلفاكير
ومشار حيث استمرت المواجهات ربما سنتين او
اكثر وهذا خطير في السودان خاصه لان
الاوضاع الانسانيه تتفاقم بشكل كبير هناك
16 مليون بحاجه الى مساعدات انسانيه هناك
نزوح في كل الاتجاهات لذلك الاوضاع فعلا
ماساويه ونحن نتكلم الان السيد محمد
كيف تجد تفاعل الاطراف الطرفين الرئيسيين
في الازمه السودانيه وهذا الصراع مع
مناشدات وخطاب وتواصل غربي من قبل مثلا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي تحدث عن
تواصل معهما وايضا الاتحاد الاوروبي هل
هناك رغبه في الاستماع في ظل حاله عدم
الثقه هل هناك اراده للاستماع الى هذه
المناشدات
وظاهريا كل طرف يحاول ان يعكس للمجتمع
الدولي بانه هو يحترم القرارات الدوليه
وكذلك يحترم المواثيقه المرتبطه
بالتداعيات الحروب او كذلك المنظمه لعمل
الحرف فيما يتعلق بالمدنيين والبياسات
الدبلوماسيه هذا ظاهريا لكن من خلال
مراجعتنا لوقت اطلاق النار والهدن الذي تم
اطلاقها مؤخرا سواء كان هدنه العيد هو
الهدنه التي سبقتها لنجد ان المواجهات
كانت مستمره القتال كان مستمر وهذا يعكس
بان الرغبه الذاتيه لطرفيه الصراع هي شبهي
معدومه وكل طرف يؤكد ويحاول ان يفرض
المعادله العسكريه باعتبار ان الفرص
المرتبطه بتسويه هذا الصراع سلميا او
التوصل الى تفاهمات هي كانت شبه معدومه
الامر الذي فرض هذا الواقع واقع الاقتتال
فبالتالي بنلاحظ ان حتى في في الهدنه او
في اثناء اجلاء الرعايه الغربيين بنلاحظ
ان هنالك التصريحات متناقضه الاداره
الامريكيه بتتحدث بانها هي نسقت مع الج
السوداني بشان اجلاء الرعايه الامريكان او
الدبلوماسيين الامريكان في الاتجاه الاخر
بنجد ان الدعم السريع يتحدث بنفس الوتيره
وبنفس الصيغه الاداره الامريكيه التنفي
كذلك فيما يتعلق بجلال الرعايه والاطقم
الدبلوماسيه الفرنسيه فبال عام هذا يعكس
لك حجم انه كله طرف بحاول ان يستقوي بورقه
المجتمع الدولي يحاول ان يظهر الشكل او
مظهر ايجابي للمجتمع الدولي بانه هو
ملتزمات لكن لك على ارض الواقع لا استجابه
فعليا لهذه الهدى في الاتجاه الاخر الوضع
الانساني الان يتعقد اكثر مما هو عليه
وهذا انا في تقديري سيجعل الخرطوم كثير من
السودان تعاني الامرين في مقبل الايام
باعتبار انها تلك الغطقم الدبلوماسيه التي
كانت في الخرطوم بشكل او باخر تحاول ان
تفرض واقع جديد بالتواصل مع اطراف الازمه
بالضغط عليها بالرغم
الممثل الخاص للامم المتحده فيرس موجود في
الخرطوم لكن فرص المساحات الحركه هي ستك
معدومه في ظل تراجعك كامل لخدمات الانترنت
في ظل استمرار القتال لكن ايضا انا الحص
هنالك بادره ربما تكون ايجابيه وربما تشير
بان هنالك شيء الان يدار في خلف الكواليس
باعتبار ان التصريحات التي صدرت مؤخرا
سواء كان محمد حمدان دقلو اثناء تواصله مع
بوريل او الاداره الامريكيه لنرى فيها شيء
من المرونه مقارنه مع التصريحات الفائته
وكذلك البرهان بالبدل الطرفين يتحدثون عن
ضروره القاء القبض على الاخر وتسليمه الى
القضاء هما الى ذلك حسم المعارك عسكريه
فقط لكن الان الكل يتحدث عن ضروره التوصل
الى تفاهمات او التوصل الى الى وقت دائما
اطلاق النار ومن بعد التحدث في في كيفيه
التواصل
نعم مختلفه من قبل طرفي النزاع في السودان
الان في الناظر الى تصريحات الطرفين هنالك
نظره مختلفه تماما حتى في المؤسسه
العسكريه هنالك مثل رئيس تحرير صحيفه
القوات المسلحه يعتبر من الصقور والذين
اصيبوا في اول المعركه الان خطابه في
تصريحاته في الفيسبوك وفي تويتر مختلفه
تماما وكذلك مستشارين محمد حمدان خطابهم
مختلف تماما انا من خلال هذه التحليلات
اؤكد ان هنالك تحركات لا سيما من الدول
الخليجيه التي لديها تاثير كبير على اطراف
الصرع اعني هنا المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والامارات العربيه المتحده وربما الحديث
عن هل هناك قمه ستعقد في الرياض ربما تكون
هذه الاحاديث الصحيحه وننتظر الايام
المقبله حتى تؤكد
ما هي الاوراق التي يملكها الاتحاد
الاوروبي ليكون فاعل في عمليه التاثير على
طرفي الصراع في السودان
وكي يعني يفعل هذا الخطاب الذي يحث فيه
الى على وقف
اطلاق النار والذهاب الى ملف الحوار
السياسي والى طاوله التفاوض
والتسويه خاصه بان يعني الاتحاد الاوروبي
البعثات تنسحب من على الارض هل بالامكان
ان تكون فاعله وهي تغادر المكان
لم تغادر المكان فعليا اسافير الاتحاد
الاوروبي قد تعرض لاعتداء منذ اسبوع
خلال الاشتباكات مستمر في وجوده في البلاد
وفي مكان مختلف بعض الدبلوماسيين
الاوروبيين الاخرين لا يزالون موجودين
ولكن نتفهم في هذه الظروف ان يكون
اوروبيون عرب مهما كانوا مهما كان
جنسياتهم ان يسعوا الى المغادره فالوضع
خطير جدا اذا هذا امر مفروغ منه في هذه
الاثناء اذا كان فعلا هناك اي جهود
للجمع بين الطرفين في الرياض او في اي
مكان اقار هذا ايجابي يبقى ان نرى ان كان
هذا سوف يتبلور فعليا ام لا بالنسبه الى
تاثيرات الاطراف كما تحدث احد الزملاء
قبلي
تاثير محدود نعود الى موضوع السلاح
هناك عدد من الاطراف المؤثره مثل مجموعه
فاجنر من روسيا التي لديها مصالح في
انتاجيه الذهب
وايضا في علاقتها مع حماتي
وربما قد تكون مشاركه في توفير الاسلحه
لحمايه هذا امر يجب ان يتوقف ليس فقط
مجموعه فاجنرال كل طرف اخر
تجد في السودان فردوسا لها الان لابد من
انفاذ حظر الاسلحه الصادر عن الامم
المتحده من اجل ان نضغط على الفريقين
البرهان وحميتي لكي نظر روما ان الاسره
الدوليه جديه في محاوله
ما هي الاوراق لدى الاتحاد الاوروبي للضغط
هي محدوده جدا
الاتحاد الاوروبي فرض عقوباتا لفتره طويله
منذ ازمه دارفور مدعشين عاما على السودان
ليس هناك عقبه جديده يمكن ان تفرد
كما اسلفت حظر الاسلحه مفروض على البلاد
ولكن عدا ذلك
الادوات او الاوراق محدوده المساعدات
الانسانيه عنصر مهم ولكن لا اعتقد ان هذين
الجنرلين يقلقان من التابعات الانسانيه
لتحركاتهما واضحا انهما لا يحترمان الحياه
الانسانيه وحقوق الانسان لقد هجر الالاف
الكثير منهم غدروا البلاد ولا يهمهما
الاتحاد الاوروبي يريد ان يوفر الدعم
الانساني اذا تمكن من ذلك هذا الظروف ولكن
الامر من حيث اوراق الضغط فهي محدوده جدا
ولا يهم الجنرالان سيد عبد الحميد سيد عبد
الحميد مع مثل محدوديه الاوراق التي
تمتلكها الدول الغربيه وايضا تحدثت عن
محدوديه ايضا فاعليه الامم
المتحده
وايضا عن ادوار لدول اقليميه من الممكن ان
تنتج اي من
محركات تدفع الطرفين للجلوس الى طاوله
المفاوضات هل برايك
يمكن ان يجري تفعيل مثلا اليات من قبل
الاتحاد الافريقي منظمه الايجاد لتكون
فاعله اكثر كمحيط اقليمي يعني معني بمثل
هذا الصراع
يعني هذه امنيات انا اتمنى ان يقوم
الاتحاد الافريقي
بالشراكه مع ايجاد ومع بعض دول الخليج
المؤثره كما تعرفون والجامعه العربيه
بارسال وفد حتى لو كان هناك مخاطره ان يصل
الوفد الى ام درمان او الى بورسودان
وينتقل الى الخرطوم للقاء
الاطراف يعني حصلت من قبل ان يكون هناك
وفود حتى اثناء المعارك
ويتم تحديد المسار ويتم اللقاء الاطراف
لكن انا ارى ان ذلك غير الان لا يوجد في
ذهن احد مثل هذا الوفد الذي سيصل الى
الخرطوم الوحيد الذي عرض ان يصل الى
الخرطوم هو من جنوب السودان وتعرفون يعني
جنوب السودان ليس له تاثير كثير في
المجريات يعني الوضع الان فعلا ماساوي انا
يعني اراهن كثيرا على الشعب السوداني رغم
ان الظروف صعبه
هناك انقطاع في الكهرباء وهناك وقف
التمويل والمساعدات الانسانيه توقفت
والطرق معطله وكثير من المطارات لا تعمل
لكن عندما يصل الشعب السوداني الى الى
قرار بانه لا يوجد امامه اي بديل الا ان
يتحرك
عودنا الشعب السوداني ان يقوم بمثل هذه
التحركات العظيمه في الازمات سواء عام 58
او عام 64 او في عام 85 دائما يكون الشعب
السوداني يفاجئ الجميع بانه يفرض موقفه
المجتمع الدولي لم يلتقط تلك المعادله
عندما قام الشعب السوداني واسقط عمر
البشير وقبل ان يتشارك المكون العسكري مع
المكون المدني حتى بعد ان اطاح في ثوره في
انقلاب 25 اكتوبر 2021 بالمكون المدني وتم
ابعاد او اقصاء عبد الله حمدوك ثم عاود
المج الدولي واقام علاقات واقنع المكون
العسكري لاعادته الى السلطه ثم استقال
فورا ولكن بقي يتعامل مع المكون العسكري
وهم يعرفون ان العسكر لا يؤمنون
بالديمقراطيه ولا يؤمنون بحق الشعوب في
تقرير
حكومه الحكومه التي يريدونها ولذلك
تساهلوا كثيرا مع المكون العسكري والذي
الان لم يجد مناصا الا ان يصطدم بنفسه
لانه بعد اقصاء المكون المدني الان هناك
راسان عسكريان كل يريد ان يطيح بالاخر
وهذا هو الموقف الان السيد محمد ما رايك
بمثل ما ذكر من خلال الضيفين وامكانيه ان
ياتي مثلا الحل على شكل تدخل افريقي
اقليمي وليس تدخل دولي مع ما لمسته انت من
تغير نوعي في نبره الخطاب لدى الطرفين
برهان
الاتحاد الافريقي ومنظمه شرق وسط افريقيا
لايجاد منذ لا وهل الاولى حاولوا ان
يعقدوا جلسات وجلسات لمجلس السلم والامن
الافريقي حددت حتى وفوت وينبغي ان تاتي
الى السودان رئيس دوله السودان وكينيا الا
ان هذه الاطراف تاع سيراته وامتلاكها الى
وسائل ضغط في عليه ارى ارض الواقع شبهي
معدومه يعني حتى نكون اكثر وضوحا لكن يمكن
لهذه الوفود ايضا ان تلعب دور مهم جدا
لاسيما وجنوب السودان باعتبارك هل لديها
تجربه في رعايه مباحثات السلام بين
الحكومه الانتقاليه المنقلب عليها وكذلك
حركات دارفور لكن حتى هذه الوفود لم نلمس
الجلديه اللازمه يمكن كما تحدث الضيف من
نيويورك استخدام طرق بديله اذا كان مطار
الخرطوم الان معطل يمكنها لهذه الوفود
تنزل في مطار مروي او مطار تنقله من بعد
تاتي الى الخرطوم يعني المسافه لا تتجاوز
ال 500 كلم لكن ونتيجه ايضا لعدم وضوح
الرؤيه للاتحاد الافريقي بشان هذه
وباعتبار ارن حتى الان الصوره لم تتبور
بالشكل الكافي فضلا عن وجود تاثيرات
مباشره من الاطراف التي طرح هذا الصراع في
السودان او تدعمه بشكل مباشر على الاتحاد
الافريقي سواء كان فاقنر سواء كان
الامارات سواء كان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لديها تاثير نفوس كبير جدا على
اليات وعمل اجهزه الاتحاد الافريقي
فبالتالي هي قادره على شان الحركه الاتحاد
الافريقي في التواصل الى تسويه حتى الدول
المنفرده كجنوب السودان فبالتالي المعادله
معقده جدا في في بعدها الامر بحاجه
لو سمحت
التحركات الاقليميه والتحركات من قبل
الدول المعنيه بتنسيق اوروبي خاصه مع حديث
عن وجود فاجنر وامكانيه الحديث
مع الطرف الذي يتحدث مع فاجنار وهو امر
ربما صعب في هذا التوقيت بين الاتحاد
الاوروبي وروسيا
الاتحاد الاوروبي وروسيا طبعا معقد بسبب
الحرف في اوكرانيا لكن لا اعتقد ان هذا له
تاثير مباشره محصل في السودان موقف اوروبا
والولايات المتحده قريب من موقف جامعه
الدول العربيه
ودول العربيه الاساسيه مثل الامارات
والسعوديه لا احد لديه مصلحه في دعم
استمرار هذا النزاع كلنا
للتوقف عند هذه النقطه شكرا جزيلا لك من
بروكس الاسفير جيمس موران مستشار شؤون
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا ومن نيويورك
دكتور عبد الحميد صيام الخبير في شؤون
الامم المتحده ومن باريس سيد محمد طورشين
الكاتب والباحث السياسي السوداني شكرا لكم
جميعا ختام هذه الحلقه من ما وراء الخبر
التغطيه مستمره على راس الساعه
[موسيقى]